A tennis player wins
her second straight set,
feeling like she can predict
her opponent's next move.
A musician works to master
a chord progression,
unfazed by mistakes as he repeatedly
plays the same four bars.
A scientist fails to notice her morning
alarm blare from the next room,
having analyzed data through the night.
While each of these people is immersed
in a different activity,
requiring specific skills
and knowledge sets,
all three are experiencing
what is known as flow—
a unique mental state
of effortless engagement.
And while you may not be a scientist
or professional athlete,
anyone can find flow.
This is a good thing,
as those who more frequently
experience flow report higher levels
of positive emotions, creativity,
and feelings of accomplishment.
Further, research has linked it
to increased productivity,
enhanced learning,
and academic achievement.
But what exactly is flow?
And how can we find it in our daily lives?
Flow is more than just concentrating
or paying attention.
Psychologists go so far as to define flow
as an altered state of consciousness
with several defining features.
First, those in flow tend to feel
so effortlessly engaged in a task
that time seems to fly by.
They are not easily distracted.
In contrast with cycles
of procrastination,
when it can feel impossible
to start an activity,
during flow it can feel difficult to stop.
Flow also tends to diminish feelings
of worry or self-judgment,
in turn fostering creativity.
And people report experiencing a sense
of oneness with what they’re doing,
allowing for peak performance.
Further, brain imaging studies have shown
that flow is accompanied by changes
in neural activity,
notably in regions that play a role
in attention, self-awareness,
and self-consciousness.
Despite decades of research,
many questions still remain.
How do the brains of those in flow compare
to those in other states of consciousness,
like meditation?
Does flow arising from physical
activities like sports
recruit the same brain areas
as more mental tasks like writing or math?
And scientists are still working
to understand why certain activities
are more likely to elicit flow
than others.
While we don't know for sure,
there are several theories.
For example, people more often report
finding flow when doing things
they find intrinsically motivating,
meaning activities they find purpose,
meaning, or enjoyment in.
This may include participating
in a favorite hobby,
but also tackling gratifying
assignments at work,
studying topics you find interesting,
or even completing satisfying chores.
Likewise, it may be more difficult
to find flow in tasks you do
only because you have to,
not because you want to.
Other research suggests balancing
personal skill level
with the activity’s challenge
is key for finding flow.
In other words, if a task is too easy,
you may get distracted or feel bored.
If it’s too challenging,
you may become discouraged.
The classically mesmerizing game
of Tetris, for example,
keeps skill-challenge levels in balance
by increasing the fall speed of blocks
as players get better at the game.
Still, other studies suggest
that it’s most important
that activities have clear goals
and allow you to assess
your progress along the way.
For example, practicing a song allows
you to gauge your performance
with each note.
This also may be why people find
flow when playing games of chance,
even though those games
don't require skill.
Moment-to-moment feedback may be enough
to motivate deep engagement.
While no single protocol
can guarantee flow,
there are steps you can take
to increase your chances.
Find a quiet environment free
from distracting noises or devices.
Break your tasks into small, specific
segments that are easy to track
and learn from.
Set clear end goals that are
challenging but not frustratingly so.
If you find the task to be tedious,
set additional parameters
to up the stakes.
For example, when cleaning your dishes,
attempt to finish them all
in a certain amount of time.
When running, try to keep pace
with the beat of a song.
Most importantly,
and perhaps most frustratingly,
don't focus too much on reaching flow.
That sort of distraction might just
prevent you from finding it.